[Music]
hey everybody
welcome back for another episode of
introducing
today is a really special episode
because we're going to talk about the
beautiful viola de gamba but of course i
don't play that instrument so i have
brought my
friend and colleague craig trumpeter who
is a wonderful
violated gumball player and the director
of haymarket opera company here in
chicago
hey craig hey thanks for having us me of
course
well i'm happy to be here too with you
me and this so what's the difference
actually between a uh
cello if you're a modern cello player
and you saw a gamba what strikes you as
being different well the look of it is
certainly different um
you know it has the c holes um
instead of the f holes on the cello and
the violin the the back is usually flat
and there's this little sort of sloping
area here yeah
it looks a lot like the contrabass in a
modern orchestra
actually um it's got many more strings
it has frets which is um i'm familiar
with those
yes you are yes uh they're double frets
actually
on a vial um so the frets are great
because uh
you know cello music you do play a fair
amount of double stops
double notes in and chords from time to
time in general music
but on the vial just like on the loot
you can play chords
pretty readily i wouldn't say they're
easy but it's because
the is the bridge more rounded the
bridge is more so
no it's it's more that we we play more
chords on the vial because of the frets
because we can do these kind of unusual
hand positions yeah
right that you would never do on a cello
is it because you couldn't get it in
tune
yeah it's it's i mean it's it's still a
challenge to play them in tune but it's
a lot easier than if
without frets uh they a lot of you know
some of the really virtuosic composers
like fort corey and marie
write chords away up here in the petite
norse above the fingerboards
above the frets which is um annoying
as a cello player can you pick a violet
gamba up
and just uh instantly start playing it
or is it like what is going on
no it's pretty confusing at first for
one thing it's it's
if you're a modern cellist you grow up
using a you learn to play using a
an end pin in the in the bottom just to
keep the instrument there so you're not
actually busy
holding it with a vial you have to it
takes a long time to
to figure out how to hold it without
without one so that's why this is called
the viola de gamba
then right right the gamba part refers
to your legs gamba means leg in italian
uh bracho is arm so the the
arm vials viola are the violin
family with the cello obviously had to
be held this way
but even the smallest size of gamba
violator gamba is held on your legs
but this tuning is in fourths
with a third in the middle and then more
fourths
so this instrument has a low a so just
like a lute
mm-hmm so this instrument is d on top
yeah d d a e c
g d and then it has a this instrument
has a low a
wow yeah so it's but it's very loot like
the tuning
we usually loots usually are tuned in
fourths with the third
uh in the middle and guitars uh modern
day guitars still
have a very similar tuning mostly
fourths and one third the six strings
and the
out of the six from low to high we have
all fours except the third to the second
is a major third so that's interesting
because aren't
because cellos are tuned in fifths right
and it's so it's there is this place in
the instrument when
if you're a cellist uh in the middle of
the instrument you
once you've learned how to deal with
strings that are a fourth apart
you have this weird place in the
instrument where you have to remember
that you have a third
yeah but after a while you get used to
it and it's um
it's actually really wonderful so wow
[Music]
what about the the headstock sometimes i
see as well there's like uh there's like
a carve there's always some sort of
carving like you have a beautiful spiral
yeah this one
is just a particular style you can kind
of they carved out the
um the center of it um oftentimes you'll
see a little
lady sitting up there or a lion or
something it just depended on the maker
and
and
uh they kind of did it differently
depending on which country they were
making them in i'm always jealous i want
one on my doorbell or something
just put a little decal up there yeah
right i'll start putting stickers on it
or something
so the other big uh difference between
the
violin family and the violeta gamba
family is the way you hold the bow
so on the violin or and the cello and
the viola
you put your hand on top of the stick
and you apply weight to the stick which
then pushes the hair into the
strings okay so you can play pretty
strong you know
concerti dance music and that kind of
thing
but on on a vial you actually are
dealing directly with the hair itself so
you put your fingers kind of thread them
through
and then you it's a much lighter
approach
and it but it's a little bit more like
speaking you have quite a lot of
well that didn't work
you can really play with these really
fine articulations
so because you're controlling the hair
as well as the stick itself
you're not it's it's funny i don't think
about to think about the stick much at
all the stick is like there to keep the
bow hair tight
right um and i'm just actually just
dealing with the hair itself yeah well
okay
so another thing that's a little bit
different for a cellist coming to this
instrument
is to um learn how to not try to
overplay it
it just doesn't make as much sound so
you have to get comfortable with
you know the aspect of that you talked
about it with
being a loot player that you know
there's just not a lot coming out
the harder you try the worse it sounds
actually so you can't
when you're coming off your songs and
your dvorak concerti
it feels quite different i think the
the vile and the loot probably went the
same way
it met the same demise in the in the 17
or the 18th century excuse me um
with the advent of the orchestra and the
larger opera house and the string
quartet you know the
the cello sort of took over and the vial
was just it became the instrument for
like sort of connoisseurs
and uh but it's really it's uh the
perfect instrument to play polyphony
so right up until um you know the
the 18th century you were playing this
wonderful repertoire that
works so beautifully on an instrument
like this because the sound is
is very clear but it's not opaque you
can hear through it and you can hear
multiple lines
at the same time so so actually you know
now that i'm thinking about it
i'm realizing that i don't even know
when the the gamba came into existence
around 1600 maybe
no no it's really um i always think
basically it's
it's the same time as columbus uh
arriving in the americas
okay um and uh the the vial
had sort of been developing probably no
one knows for sure but
in spain uh before that and then it was
ferdinand and isabella kicked out all
the jews from spain and a lot of them
went to italy
and brought these uh these sort of
instruments that were maybe
in between a plucked uh vihuela
and viola de arco they were kind of it
was like a
boat guitar bowed loot and they brought
them to italy
and then from there they just developed
into something a little bit different
in the in the um renaissance period
the vial would have been used to play
textless madrigals so you could just
take a madrigal and just play
instead of singing it oh yeah uh you
could do the same with masses and motets
um so there's this you know kind of
endless repertoire that you can do there
uh and some of that in the in the 17th
century in england particularly
uh there was this sort of resurgence of
activity with the vial
and a lot of really wonderful fantasias
were written
by all the greats bird and and laws and
personal uh so there's a really
wonderful
rich repertoire there and then we kind
of get into more the soloistic
rep of the 18th century and you know
you're more likely you'll most likely
hear this instrument if you go hear
one of the bach passions because there's
a
beautiful gamba solo in each one yeah
you know
i think uh i think we had this
conversation once but
am i am i mistaken to say that most
gamble players nowadays at least
discover the gamba through uh that
wonderful
french movie to limatan dumont tulemata
yeah so uh in fact i did really i had
already been playing
for a few years when it when the movie
came out
but i didn't really know what i had
never really
heard a vial except my own under my own
fingers
right and i do think that a lot of vile
players myself included were inspired
by it earlier we were talking about the
um
different sizes of the vial this is a
treble vial
treble gamba you would also hold it on
your lap like this
vertically so i mean so while it could
fit under your neck it's
it's uh better played this way and then
there are
several other sizes there's a an alto
vial which is a little larger than this
then there are two sizes of tenors
there's the base and then there's a big
violone uh
which you would play almost standing up
or at least sitting on a high stool
and then there's also two other um at
least two other instruments we think
that were um used for very specific
repertoires there was the lira vial
in england which uh uh would
tobias hume would have played for
tobacco
for that song um we actually got a
little take of
craig singing and playing the tobiah
assumed tobacco we should hear it now
[Music]
is
[Music]
so i've strung my treble vial in all gut
there are there are no wound strings on
it
and it works fine just because it's it's
you know the lowest note is a d
the d below middle c right so it's not
that big of a string but once you get to
this guy the the the bass instruments
really needed to have
over spun strings and by that you mean
like with metal
yeah um it wants you know to play
certain repertoires you can you can
play earlier rep up until maybe the
mid 17th century on um all gut
strung so here's here's a little sample
of the treble vial
[Music]
that's gorgeous it's so uh it's a vocal
yeah and uh really that piece that
little bit of uh snippet of personal
that i just played is
one of the last pieces written for the
violator gamba consort uh
yeah so and that was in the you know the
1680s
well i'd be interested in trying to
pluck one of these things and seeing how
my loot
technique works maybe the maybe the
little one sure let's do it i'm afraid
of the big one
whoa gonna use loop shapes here
it works
[Music]
see if i can try a philia
[Music]
whoa there it is
[Music]
that is so much fun to play well i think
i won't be sounding good on this anytime
soon
but thank you for letting me try well
this is so cool i
i i feel like you've answered so many
questions that i've always wanted to
know
about the gamba and now i just feel like
i have to go
deeper so thanks for doing this
absolutely it's my pleasure
you have uh hey market has a really cool
event coming up right
yeah we so we're we're celebrating our
10th season uh
this year and we're it's an all handle
season so we're doing
three of my favorite pieces uh asus and
galatia
uh apollo et daphne and then orlando
uh and we're filming them in a in a um
a film studio so it'll be uh no live
audience because we're trying to protect
our
our patrons um and our artists as well
uh so the orchestra will be masked and
of course you'll have your mask on
um and uh it's gonna be a really fun uh
beautiful season of music i'm really
excited about it i can't wait to be a
part of it
how can people check it out so if you go
to haymarketopera.org
uh you can buy tickets and they're
pretty inexpensive uh
the first show is october 30th aces and
galatia and then
uh apollo daphne is march 5th and
orlando will be next
june fantastic this will be a really
special thing so please do
check that out yes cool thanks greg
thank you
all right thanks for watching guys
[Music]
you